in my desperate recent attempts to find
an anime that would truly engross me
one that could reel me in with its
intensity and refuse to let go until it
was over
i actually stumbled upon a rather
well-ranked but
forgotten anime one that i was surprised
to find was originally written by the
critically acclaimed yukimura makoto
in the years leading up to his hit
series which i'm sure you'll recognize
finland saga a series that i just
recently happened to binge read through
and so it felt like a natural next step
for me to explore his next work or what
was actually his debut work
his very first manga one that after
watching it now
i'm sure would have gone down in the
books were it not soon overshadowed by
vinland saga
and so i sat back and dug into planets
what i initially expected to be a
thrilling space odyssey
unaware that it would soon unravel into
one of the most philosophical
and existential stories i have ever
witnessed
the story begins in 2075 and commercial
space travel is no longer a dream
people live on the moon interplanetary
space travel is commonplace
and large space corporations of course
have monopolized and control much of
outer space
as a result of significant space
exploration though the problem of space
debris has evolved into a massive issue
with only single bolts wandering through
the galaxy being able to destroy
huge spacecrafts in one go and as such
we follow the space debris section of a
large conglomerate company called
teknora
who clean up space junk and as a result
are considered to be the bottom
of the outer space food chain as just
mere trashmen
and we are initially introduced to ai
tanabe as she joins a group of
incredibly unique
but human and goal driven debris
collectors living among the stars
in a way space is the ultimate the best
backdrop for
any kind of story wanting to follow
characters pursuing their dreams
it embodies the endless possibilities
the infinity of being able to do
whatever you want
but while the story initially focuses on
i as seemingly the main character
the focus of the show soon shifts to her
fellow astronaut
coined as the diaper man hoshino but who
we
ultimately come to know as hachimaki
named after the traditional japanese
headband he wears what is historically
worn in japan
as a symbol of effort and courage it
truly represents his ambitious
and unwavering character hachimaki is
determined to someday own his own
spaceship
which of course lies far out of the
imaginable financial range for a mere
space trashman
as they are thought of within the
company but he takes his job
and his dreams very seriously he is
quick to punch and beat anyone who makes
fun of the debris section
and constantly shuns eye if she doesn't
take being an astronaut in space
as seriously as the life or death
situation that it
actually is and it is through this
constant discrimination and
underdog story that we first learn of
and immerse ourselves with this group of
characters
these people who against all odds or
trying to make their individual dreams
come true
in what feels like a very normal slice
of life story amidst the backdrop of
space in the first half of the series
and then everything
now this video it's it's different from
what i usually do
it's extremely rooted in real issues
real
issues about humanity but that's because
so is this anime
and it's one of the very few times that
a show has resonated with me on such a
personal level
i'm pretty good at distancing my own
story and life
from anime but attributed to good
writing from yukimura or just a good
anime
planets felt different and the three
central
aspects of this show that i'll focus on
that it very
deeply explores and work together to
ultimately question
what humanity is are human ambition
class discrimination and purpose
arguably the biggest theme permeating
through this show something you witness
on a small scale in every single
character and
in the broader sense of things in simply
the premise of the series
is human ambition and most of all the
show constantly raises the question
of whether there is an end to human
ambition
we use all the oil on earth for the sake
of advancing technology
and once that was dried up we moved to
space we found deuterium and helium-3
on the moon and continue to use that
instead to fuel our ships
we simply move from one source to
another once the first gets depleted
is human ambition so strong that
stripping the world of its health
pushing us further to an uninhabitable
planet are nothing but
small prices to pay along the way i
found this to be an
ironically pertinent issue when i watch
this especially considering jeff bezos's
recent launch
into space or rather his 12-minute
joyride
humanity has reached the next stage of
evolution where releasing
countless tons of carbon emissions and
millions of dollars funding
are simply a means to launch a man into
space just so he can see what it's like
just give a glimpse of what's there and
return
there's no functional purpose no
scientific advancement
it's simply humans testing what they can
do
their limits and the show dotes heavily
on this topic
the central antagonist of the series is
the space defense front
a terrorist organization that believes
humanity never should have gone into
space in the first place
instead of dealing with issues on earth
addressing the lack of
oil or damage to the environment
humanity decided to just
get up and move on to space and pillage
that instead
as a mere human in this day and age
looking at what is happening around
us you can't help but see our current
world reflected
in the one in planets that was written
20 years ago
sure i suppose if humanity is able to
move on to space and supply ourselves
there
there isn't an inherent problem with it
i have no qualms
but is ambition nothing more than
humanity
feeding off of what lies around us for
our own sake
must it always come at such a great cost
planets
strikes that fear into you this show
is the ultimate critique of the monster
of capitalism
the terrorist organization brings
attention to a huge goal of the
higher-ups in the show
which is to man the first ship to
jupiter billions
of dollars and human workers going into
expanding our knowledge
when people back on earth suffer it's
it's almost too real for an anime and
that actually brings me into my next
point
of class discrimination
there are many points in the show that
very explicitly demonstrate the effects
of class discrimination it's
it's not very subtle we are thrown into
the very beginning of the story
immediately seeing the poor treatment of
the debris section
we see them as the bottom of the barrel
they're the underdogs of the story and
remain as such throughout but then we
soon come to see that even they
are amongst the privileged as people
from third world countries are
outright refused the option to join in
on the scientific race
of these space conglomerates our main
characters are japanese they're
american they're members of this
international organization of first
world countries called
into the space defense front's biggest
problem with the project to go to
jupiter
is that the resources gathered there
will be distributed proportionally to
the countries and companies that
funded it it is the classic dilemma of
making the rich
even richer poor countries with starving
children and unvaccinated people reap no
benefit from the advancements of
so-called humanity
and the debris section often clashed
with the company because in a way
they are the only people in this entire
show who are working solely for a
purpose separate from financial gain
cleaning up space though it's the bottom
of the barrel
saves lives from potentially
life-threatening stuff
the section doesn't perform well
financially it's understaffed
and this is why our characters are the
perfect heroes for this story
they can sympathize with being at the
bottom and unlike many other top dogs in
the company
are never driven by the organization's
gains or money
just cleaning up and saving people the
rich directors of their company often
try and push them around but
can't because what they're doing is
morally right
in a world where the ones fighting for
humanity are thought of as terrorists
is that the kind of world we want to
live in
is the world of planets is this universe
something that we
want to reach and just another mention
of jeff bezos going to space because
i can't get over this super villain
right here hell yes
[Laughter]
it's just more mirroring of planets of
the rich doing what they want
sending a rocket into space for 12
minutes and just slapping the ozone
layer right in the face while he's at it
it's interesting to see 20 years after
this story was written
how things are exactly the same or
actually following in the footsteps
building up to exactly that foretold
future planets
acts as such an ominous foreboding of
what is to come
and what has already happened
and last of all purpose and this one
is the most integral to the story and
the characters themselves
it has nothing to do with class or the
government or money
just hachimaki hachimaki after he is
psychologically damaged at some point in
the story
loses one of the most integral traits of
being an astronaut
remaining calm and collected in the
endless vacuum of space
and what i love about this small sub-arc
specifically something the show makes
very
clear is that the problem is solely
mental
it is just a matter of mindset of
psychological torment
but losing the ability to remain calm in
space
is arguably the most detrimental
possible thing that can happen
to an aspiring astronaut and it's all in
hachimaki's head
and it is through this arc that we see
an incredibly deep and self-reflective
telling of hachimaki's character
one of my favorites and most realistic
i've ever seen in anime
because as hashimaki struggles with it
he begins to even believe
that it's his own fault that this
psychological torment was
all caused by himself that perhaps there
is a part of him that has always punched
people looking down on him and made out
of reach dreams
all as part of a show as a way to excuse
his complacency at his job as a debris
collector because
the goal is simply out of reach it's far
away that he's just using it as a means
of truly trying for nothing
and he chose a goal so impossible to
achieve
so he would never have to really aspire
for anything realistic
and now that part of him it's surfacing
it's telling him
to stop everyone in their life questions
their path
their purpose are my aspirations too
lofty
am i just finding ways and excuses to
remain complacent
hachimaki both in name and character is
the embodiment of willpower and courage
and this psychological barrier is the
sole possible thing
he needed in the show to develop his
character and grow
to see whether that courage is just a
facade or if he can really make his
aspirations come true
i have dreams of my own i want to get a
good job someday and have a family and
watching hachimaki made me think
what am i doing to get there am i the
same am i just living day in
and day out lazing around thinking it's
an
inevitability well perhaps it's only a
slim
possibility and the medium in which the
show does this mental questioning
is amazing because hachimaki's problem
is the fear of
space of the darkness the loneliness and
the endlessness
of what i mentioned earlier as the
perfect setting for endless
possibilities
he is scared of the future and the path
he might take to get there
in space he is alone he is the only one
he can question
and more so than other shows planets
establishes this
incredibly introspective and existential
questioning
both through the character and through
the atmosphere in the setting
and that is why it works so perfectly
now this video raised a lot of lofty
questions a lot of things that
probably can never be answered but if
if i had to summarize what planets said
to me
what it asked me by the very end it is
are your dreams for humankind for the
benefits of others
or are they just for yourself
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
[Music]
analyses
you